four tips for repurposing your existing
content in a smart way one of the best
ways to do this is to turn long form
content into Clips a clip is anything
from one minute to probably 10 minutes
and a great example of this is Dave
Ramsey Now Dave Ramsey is a personal
finance teacher he helps people get out
of debt he's famous for telling people
to cut up their credit cards and what
Dave Ramsey does is a live show five
days a week on personal finance and
getting out of debt Dave actually has
two different YouTube channels and on
his Dave Ramsey live YouTube channel
that is where the live stream happens
every day for two hours or they upload
the replay of the two-hour show now
Dave's been doing this for a long time
he's got an entire team and other
personalities but just for some math to
prove how powerful this is in this last
month that channel got 2.4 million views
the long form content got two point four
million views in a month but after the
two hour long form videos are live
streamed or uploaded they're then turned
into shorter Clips which in this case
are uploaded on a different Channel and
so on that channel they've uploaded 61
videos essentially highlights or clips
that are all around seven minutes each
some of them are four minutes some of
them are nine minutes but here's the
crazy part in a month's time that
channel got 10.3 million views this is
one of the reasons why we love video
podcasting here at think media because
you can create long form content and
then ultimately repurpose clips from
that content number two is long form
into YouTube shorts what's the
difference well YouTube short is going
to be less than one minute a clip is
going to be a horizontal or landscape
video whereas a short is going to be a
vertical video tip number three is
content tent marathons this is one of my
favorite strategies that literally
nobody else talks about that I've found
on the internet to get the big idea let
me ask you a question have you ever seen
a viral Tick Tock compilation this is
actually where people download multiple
different tick tocks stitch them all
together and upload a 10 or 20 minute
video on YouTube that a lot of times can
get millions of views so imagine if you
took videos from your library combine
them into one larger video and then
uploaded that longer video to your
channel this is why we call this smart
repurposing because the more you plan in
advance the more that you look down the
road and structure your content the
better the results you can get for
example if you were to create a video
series part one is 10 minutes part two
is 10 minutes part three part four Etc
about 40 minutes of content where you
could upload each of those videos
separately perhaps you could upload some
shorter clips from those videos as well
but then you could Stitch all of those
videos together and upload an extra long
video that's 40 minutes this might sound
crazy but it's incredibly powerful and
oftentimes super long content especially
education content can perform very well
on YouTube and then number four is to
post your vertical videos on other
social media platforms again the goal
here is to take all of the energy all
the creativity and all of the hard work
that you put into creating content and
ultimately get more mileage and impact
and reach out of the one piece of
content you're creating and so if you
create a vertical video why would you
only upload it on YouTube shorts why not
also upload it on Instagram and Tick
Tock and Facebook reels you know I
mentioned Jeff Moore's earlier from
Rhythm Church their YouTube channel just
hit a thousand subscribers super cool
milestone for their community in their
church but those sermon clips that are
short vertical videos coming out of his
longer 40-minute sermons are not just
being uploaded his YouTube shorts
they're also going on Facebook they're
also going on Instagram and they're
ultimately able to then encourage people
inspire people bring awareness to that
local church grow followers on the
different platforms and all because
you're working smarter and not harder
all because you're tapping into the
power of intelligently dividing up and
repurposing your content so that it can
reach further than ever before two
things number one I've had too much
coffee today number two if you have not
seen our free master class yet you're
gonna love it if you're serious about
growing your YouTube channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class